Hey, everyone, Ryan here, and welcome to our Practice Questions video for the Head and
Neck Anatomy Series.
This is everything that we talked about in this video series, and if you haven't already,
I would definitely encourage you to go back and watch all of these videos before attempting
these questions to give you the best chance of doing well.
I broke down the material covered on the board exam into 19 videos of high yield information,
and this information will really help you on the board exam, especially the information
about the muscles of mastication, facial expression, and tongue innervation.
Now I've compiled 15 questions for us to go through together, and these will be very
similar to what you see on test day, so keep track of how you do, and let me know in the
comments once we're done.
Alright, so enough with that, let's get started with question number one.
And now that we're working on the integrated board exam, I've included a patient box with
many of these practice questions, so you get some practice on working through them.
Now this is the board exam's way of presenting information about a patient case.
It's standardized, it looks the same every time it's presented on the board exam with
these four sections.
Now sometimes one of these four sections, or maybe two of them will be left blank, but
most of the time there's some information in all of these sections.
Alright so go ahead, read through this question, and think through the answer choices, and
we'll go over it together.
Alright so this one says which muscle is most likely failing to act properly in this case.
Now most of the time when I have a case question on an exam, I would read through the question
first, then I would skim through the patient box, and then I would go to the answer choices.
It's typically the order I do things you could skim through the patient box first and then
read through the question, but I would typically wait until at least going through both of
those before going through the answer choices.
So we're looking for something muscle related, we're going through the patient box, they're
here for routine checkup.
A lot of this information is extraneous, we don't really need it to solve the question,
but this is pretty important.
During our oral cancer screening the patient's unable to protrude her tongue.
So this is talking about tongue muscle and their action.
So if we go through the answer choices, all four of those are tongue muscles, and we just
have to think about what are those muscles particular actions.
So the hyaglosis depresses the tongue, the styloglossus retracts the tongue, the palatoglossus elevates
the posterior part of the tongue, and the genealoglossus protrudes the tongue forward.
Now since the patient's unable to adequately stick her tongue out while you're doing a
oral cancer screening, you can presume that the genealoglossus is failing to act properly
because its action is responsible for sticking the tongue out and the patient's unable to
do so.
So the answer for this first question is D, the genealoglossus is failing to act properly.
Alright question number two, the facial nerve exits the skull through which for Raymond.
Go ahead pause the video, think through this question then we'll go over it together.
Okay so although we didn't talk about the Stylo mastoid for Raymond specifically in
our videos, we learned what passes through the other three foramina.
And this is an important lesson for the board exam.
Sometimes you'll see something that you just never heard of before, but typically if you've
gone through all of the high yield things that we talk about, you'll have enough information
at your disposal to answer a question even if there's something in the question stem
or in the answer choices that you just haven't heard of before, you could at least rule
out or rule in the correct answer by recognizing everything else.
So for here we know the Freeman Rotundum V2, the second division, second branch of the
trigeminal nerve traverses Rotundum, Ovali is going to transmit V3 as well as the lesser
petrosal nerve.
The Stylo mastoid for Raymond, well let's skip over that one for now and go to the jugular
foramen which transmits cranial nerves 9, 10 and 11, but the answer, the question is talking
about the facial nerve, cranial nerve 7.
And so it doesn't really seem to fit with any of these, A, B or D. And so the facial
nerve actually enters from the brain to the base of the skull through the internal acoustic
meadis and then it exits the skull through that Stylo mastoid foramen.
So the answer for this question is in fact C, that's the little Stylo mastoid foramen
and we could pick that answer because we could rule out everything else.
Rotundum, Ovali and the jugular foramen did not transmit the facial nerve from when we
learned those foramina.
So again, important lesson, you may not recognize everything but you usually have enough information
to answer it correctly.
Alright question number 3, which bone along with the maxilla and zygomatic bone formed
the floor of the orbit.
Go ahead think through this question and then we'll go over it together.
Alright so let's go through these answers one at a time.
The nasal bone is not part of it, it's typically included as a distractor option when talking
about the orbit because it's close by but it's not technically a part of it so we can
rule that one out immediately.
This phenoid bone is part of the posterior wall of the orbit but not the floor so that
one we can rule out as well.
The ethoid bone is part of the medial surface of the orbit and the palatine bone is contributing
the smallest component to the orbit but it is an important portion nonetheless as it
does involve part of the floor.
So D is the correct answer and you can see that the palatine bone, that little teal part
along with the zygomatic and maxilla are forming the floor of the orbit.
Okay question number 4, we're back to our patient boxes.
The witch muscle is activating in this patient to produce the facial expression you noticed.
Go ahead pause the video, read through that patient box and we'll go over the question
together.
Okay so this is another classic muscle action question, these come up a little more often
than some of the other head and neck anatomy things that we've went over before.
So witch muscle is activating in this patient well again we can go to the patient box and
figure out what the question stem is talking about and this is pretty common when you're
preparing to administer local anesthetic the patient may not be thrilled and you observe
that they're wrinkling the bridge of their nose and so we go through the answer choices
and think about which of these muscles could be resulting in that action.
Well the mentalis is responsible for pouting the lower lip, it contributes to mentalis
strain, doesn't have anything to do with the nose so we're going to rule that one out.
The nasalis compresses the nasal cartilage it also depresses the tip of the nose and
elevates the corners of the nostrils so does have to do with the nose but not the bridge
which is between the eyebrows so we're going to rule that one out as well.
The orbicularis oculi closes the eye in both a smiling and frowning but again doesn't have
anything to do with the bridge of the nose and that leaves us with the procerus which
does in fact wrinkle the bridge of the nose right between the two eyebrows so the correct
answer for this question is C. Now I almost included the corrugator super ciliai muscle
as a distractor option of these answers because it's very similar in action to the procerus
but it draws the eyebrows together which is often paired with wrinkling of the bridge
of the nose.
So know that on a board exam they might include the super ciliai muscle if this question were
asked but I chose to avoid including that as a possible answer choice because they are
very similar in action.
Question number five.
The Terego maxillary fissure separates the maxilla from what bone posteriorly.
Go ahead pause the video and then we'll go over this together.
So the Terego maxillary fissure is that teardrop shaped hole located at the back of the maxilla
above and behind the tuberosity.
So Terego maxillary pretty much gives you the answer the maxilla is in the front of this
fissure and the Teregoid process is in the back so if you know which bone includes the
Teregoid process you know this answer and so the bone here that includes the Teregoid
process as well as the Teregoid plates is the sphenoid bone.
And so if we look at this image from our videos this is the sphenoid bone and it's forming
that posterior border for this teardrop shaped Terego maxillary fissure.
Okay question number six.
Which two nerves carry taste sensation from the tongue?
Go ahead and pause the video and then we'll go over this together.
Alright so tongue innervation like I said at the beginning of this video is one of the
most important things you could take away from this entire series.
So we definitely definitely have to be familiar with this.
So the question is specifically asking about taste sensation and if we draw our tongue
diagram and we have the anterior two thirds the posterior third and then we have our root
or base of the tongue we can fill this in with the information from our videos.
And so for touch sensation to the anterior two thirds that is the trigeminal nerve specifically
the third division of that trigeminal nerve and even more specifically the lingual nerve
of V3.
However, that's touch sensation and we're concerned about taste.
So the lingual nerve although it sounds correct is not what we're looking for in this answer.
As far as taste from the anterior two thirds that's the facial nerve specifically courtotimpany.
And so I like this answer choice already.
And then for the posterior thirds that is the glossopharyngeal nerve for both taste
and touch sensation.
And so glossopharyngeal nerve is also correct.
So C is the correct answer and then just for fun D has this part correct but the hypoglossal
nerve is responsible for muscle action of the tongue not taste.
So the answer here is C.
Alright question number seven.
This patient is unable to protrude her mandible more than 10 millimeters.
You suspect no muscle or joint disorders.
What ligament is most likely involved with this finding?
Go ahead pause the video and then we'll go over this together.
So again it's always good practice to read the question first then read through or at
least skim the entire patient box and then go through the answer choices.
Now in this case though there's a whole lot of information in this box about condler injury,
suspected facial trauma and resultant asymmetric growth that I would call a red herring.
This is information that you don't need to answer the question.
And this will happen on the exam.
The vast majority of the time there's certainly information in here that you need but on rare
occasion it's just extraneous information that might try to even throw you off.
So just keep that in mind when you're reading through these.
The normal protrusive movement for an adult or even an adolescent patient would be somewhere
between five and twelve millimeters.
So this 10 millimeter finding is well within normal limits.
There's nothing pathologic going on here.
And the key is they're unable to protrude the mandible more than.
So we're looking for a ligament that is specifically limiting protrusion of the mandible.
So we can run through these ligaments in the answer choices and figure out which is the
best fit.
The discal ligament or collateral ligaments help the condyle and disc travel together
and they also separate the upper and lower joint spaces.
Nothing about limiting movement of the jaw though.
So we'll rule that one out.
The stylo-highway ligament runs from the styloid process to the hyroid bone, actually doesn't
attach to the mandible at all.
And it's calcified and symptomatic in eagle syndrome but doesn't limit movement of the
mandible.
So we'll rule that one out as well.
This phenomandibular ligament is an important one.
It supports the mandible but it doesn't actually limit its movement.
So we can rule that one out as well.
And the stylo-mandibular ligament that goes from the styloid process to the angle of
the mandible does limit movement.
It's the culprit for the finding why we don't just have the mandible protruding twelve, fifteen
and twenty millimeters because it prohibits that mandible from stretching beyond a certain
point.
So the answer in this question is A.
Alright question number eight.
The masseter muscle originates from what skeletal structure.
Go ahead and pause the video and then we'll go over this together.
Alright so this is a nice straight forward muscle question and it's really just pure
rote memorization.
The masseter muscle is one of those main muscles of mastication so it's absolutely fair game
for the board exam.
The infrared temporal crest is the origin of the superior head of the lateral pterogoid
muscle, not the masseter.
So we can rule that one out.
The lateral pterogoid plate is the origin for both pterogoids depending on the surface,
ideal for medial pterogoid and lateral surface for lateral pterogoid muscle.
So we can rule that one out as well and the mandibular angle is perhaps the most tempting
of these incorrect choices and it's the insertion of the masseter but we're looking for the
origin so this is also incorrect.
The correct answer here is zygomatic arch and that is where the masseter attaches.
Alright question number 9, which of the following muscles is least likely to be activated during
a smile?
Go ahead pause the video and then we'll go over this one together.
Alright so all of these muscles except for one is involved in smiling.
The orbicularis oculi that surrounds both eyes is involved in squinting of the eye which
does happen during a duchine or candid enjoyment smile.
So that is incorrect.
It does actually activate.
The rhizoreous muscle is one of those smiling muscles as well.
It pulls the corners of the lip laterally particularly during a grimace that's also incorrect.
The zygomatic is major is perhaps the main smiling muscle that one is definitely incorrect
and the elevator angular ores elevates the corner of the mouth on both sides and so that's
definitely going to activate during a smile pulling up the corners of the lips so that
is also incorrect.
And perhaps ironically the orbicularis ores that surrounds the mouth is actually the only
one that's activated not during a smile here.
It's only activated during puckering and frowning.
So the orbicularis ores is maybe counter-intuitively the correct answer for this question.
It activates during a frown but not during a smile.
Alright question number 10 go ahead and read through this question and the patient box
and then we'll go over it together.
So which salivary duct is most likely involved in the condition responsible for her bad taste.
So what are they talking about?
Let's go to the patient box and find out.
So we have an older female patient.
My mouth feels very dry.
Have a bad taste.
Difficulty swallowing, strange tasting saliva and difficulty keeping her dentures in place.
Early edentulous, complete upper and lower dentures and oh this is interesting reveals
a radiopaque mask consistent with scialo lithiasis.
So older patient sounds like maybe she has Shogren syndrome or maybe it's a side effect
of polypharmacy.
We don't know why she has a dry mouth and frankly we don't care.
We don't need to know.
But what's important is this, the scialo lithiasis.
It's a calcification in a salivary gland duct and the submandibular gland has the highest
predilection for scialo lithiasis with about 80% occurrence rate followed by the prided
gland at about 19% and then sublingual glands for the remaining 1%.
But the question doesn't include the salivary glands as answer choices instead it's talking
about the salivary ducts which is where these calcifications tend to occur.
So we have to find the one that correlates to the submandibular gland.
So if we go through these answer choices one at a time, the Stenson's duct has to do with
the prided gland so that is not correct.
Bartholins duct is part of the ducts of Rivenis which have to do with the sublingual gland
that's also incorrect and the von Eppner's glands are glands found in a trough circling
the circumvalleyed papillae on the dorsal surface of the tongue near the terminal sulcus.
And although it has to do with the tongue and taste buds although the bad taste might
tempt you to pick this answer choice.
The source of that bad taste is the scialo lith and this has nothing to do with calcifications
in a salivary gland duct.
So we're going to rule that one out as well.
Wartin's duct does connect to the submandibular gland and so that is the correct answer.
The submandibular gland is also responsible for producing the majority of our saliva.
Alright question number 11, which skull suture do you expect has fused early in this patient?
Go ahead pause the video and then we'll go over this together.
So here we have an 8 year old male.
His parent says, "My child has an underbite and I'm concerned about his adult teeth not
coming in.
And current findings include frontal bossing of the skull, hypertealarism, increased distance
between the eyes, proptosis which is bulging eyes, and a hypoplastic or a retrusive maxilla.
They're currently in primary dentition with multiple impacted permanent teeth."
So really the first part of solving this puzzle is figuring out this child's diagnosis.
And all these findings together point towards a syndrome being cruzon syndrome.
Now the second half of this puzzle is determining the suture involved in early fusion.
Now cruzon's patients present with brachycephaly, that's a short skull antaroposterially, which
we talked about when we talked about skull sutures.
So it makes sense that a suture that runs horizontally would most likely be involved
in a craniosynostosis that results in a short AP or antaroposterior skull.
So the only one of these that runs horizontally is the coronal suture.
And the coronal suture is in fact the one that tends to be fused early in these cruzon and
apert patients.
And so we can see here again from our drawing that the frontal or metopic, the sagittal and
the squamous sutures all run from this view a vertical direction, and the coronal is the
only one that runs in a horizontal direction, which is going to prohibit the skull from
expanding along that axis.
So the coronal suture is the correct answer for this question.
All right, question number 12, which of the following structures does not border the infected
facial space, go ahead pause the video and then we'll talk about this one together.
So here we have a 25 year old male.
His face is swollen and he cannot open his mouth.
This is called trismus.
And his previous dentist inadvertently used a contaminated needle and infected a facial
space during an inferior alveolar nerve block.
So this is interesting.
That has resulted in trismus and lateral facial swelling.
And so which of the following structures does not border the infected facial space?
Well, what we have to first know is which facial space is infected.
And the one that's typically involved with an inferior alveolar nerve block is the Terego
mandibular space.
If we draw our diamond, this is my shortcut for the masticator spaces.
And so we have the zygomatic arch here.
We have the mandible that goes down here.
We have the skull right up here and we have a couple of muscles of mastication.
We have the mastider muscle, the medial pterogoid, the lateral pterogoid and the temporalis.
And so the space that we're really interested in is, again, the Terego mandibular space,
which is located between the lateral pterogoid muscle and the mandible.
And so which of the following structures does not border that infected facial space?
Well, we just talked about we have the mandibular ramus.
We have the lateral pterogoid muscle and we have the medial pterogoid muscle.
And so we can rule out medial pterogoid, we can rule out lateral pterogoid.
Now, the interesting thing is we said mandibular ramus because that's the vertical part of
the mandible.
But the mandibular body is located too far down and it's not involved in this facial
space.
You can think back where we're doing an inferior alveolar nerve block.
The body is located too far forward and down.
For comprehensiveness sake, let's talk about every single boundary of this Terego mandibular
space.
And superiorly, we have the inferior head of the lateral pterogoid, laterally, we have
the medial surface of the mandibular ramus, medially, we have the medial pterogoid muscle,
posteriorly, we have the deep part of the parotid gland and anteriorly, we have the Terego
mandibular refe.
And so the parotid gland is in fact a deep or posterior boundary for this space.
The mandibular body is not, it's actually the mandibular ramus.
So pretty challenging question here, but the correct answer for which of the following
does not border the Terego mandibular space is the mandibular body.
And here's that diagram that I was drawing before.
All right, question number 13, now the following three questions all have to do with the same
case.
So this is a classic example of a case set where you're given one patient, then several
questions concerning that single patient.
So you decide to conduct a cranial nerve exam for this patient.
First you ask her to follow your finger with her eyes, making sure to test for full range
of motion of each eye, which of the following cranial nerves have you not tested?
So go ahead, read through this question, the patient box, and then we'll go over it together.
Okay, so here we have a 60 year old female, she hasn't been to the dentist in a while,
and she has a history of Bell's palsy.
So that's facial paralysis on one side of the face.
So a cranial nerve exam might be a good idea to test her range of motion and see what's
going on.
So for this first part of the cranial nerve exam, we're asking her to follow our finger.
So she's moving the pupils of her eyes up and down left and right, and we're testing
for a complete full range of motion.
So the cranial nerves here, three, oculomotor, four, and six, are all controlling extraocular
eye muscles.
Three is controlling most of those muscles, and then we have our SO4LR6, so superior oblique
and lateral rectus.
Now the trigeminal nerve not involved in this, it's involved in sensation of the face, we
have some tongue innervation going on.
So this is not involving the activity of the eye.
So the answer for this first question of the case set is C. Now I might even make the argument
that this test of testing their full range of motion of the eye really doesn't test the
cranial nerve to either, that's the optic nerve.
That would be done with a field of view test and a visual acuity test like you'd have
at the eye doctor where you have to read certain letters from a certain distance.
And so my point for bringing that up is that if one of the answer choices was cranial nerve
2, I probably would select that as the correct answer as well because this specific test
is not really testing the activity of cranial nerve 2 specifically, it's more focusing on
the actual muscle movements of the eye.
Can both eyes accurately move in both in all directions?
So the answer for this first one is C. Then the second question for the case is next you
ask the patient to say ah and observe movement at the soft palate.
Which of the following cranial nerves are you testing now?
Go ahead pause the video and then we'll go through this together.
So motor movement of all soft palate muscles except the tensor of belly palatini is controlled
by the vagus nerve.
So the answer to this one is going to be cranial nerve 10, the vagus nerve.
Now if we go through the incorrect choices, the facial nerve does facial expressions which
are not relevant here, the glossopharyngeal nerve is responsible for the sensory gag reflex
but not motor movements of the soft palate when you're saying something like ah.
So that's also incorrect.
And the hypoglossal nerve does activate when you say ah if you stick your tongue out like
at the doctor's office but that has to do with tongue movement, not soft palate movement
which the question stem points out.
So we're looking for soft palate vibration which is activated by cranial nerve 10 or
the vagus nerve.
And finally you ask the patient to shrug their shoulders.
Which of the following cranial nerves are you testing now?
Go ahead pause the video and then we'll go through this together.
Alright so for this last question, the main muscle that shrugs the shoulder is the trapezius
muscle and it's one of the two muscles that's innervated by the spinal accessory nerve which
is cranial nerve 11.
So the answer for this final question of these practice questions is D.
Alright so how'd you do?
Let me know in the comments.
I know some of these questions were pretty challenging.
I definitely didn't make it easy on you guys.
So hopefully don't get discouraged if you got a couple wrong.
These are pretty accurate in terms of what you might see on the board exam.
So take it as a learning experience and keep at it and keep studying and you'll do really
really well.
So that's it for this video guys.
Thank you so much for watching.
Please like this video if you enjoyed it and subscribe to this channel for more on dentistry.
If you're interested in supporting this channel and what I do, please check out my Patreon
page.
Thank you to all of my patrons for all their support.
You can unlock extras like access to my video slides to take notes on and practice questions
for the board exams.
So go check that out.
The link will be in the description.
Thanks again for watching everyone and I'll see you in the next video.